[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
as a professor of astrophysics you might
be shocked to learn i don't believe in
the law of gravity i don't believe in
black holes
i don't even believe the sun rises in
the east
i don't have to believe in these things
because
i have evidence for them for centuries
scientists have used evidence to test
their ideas of the physical world
it's called the scientific method and
it's the most powerful knowledge
generation tool
ever invented in contrast it's common to
use words like belief or faith when
discussing
god although the universe seems
tuned for our existence even the
faithful admit there's no cold hard
evidence that such a tuner exists they
take it
on faith because of the lack of cold
hard data
it's probably not surprising that over
70 percent
of the national academy of sciences the
most prestigious
association of scientists in the united
states do not believe in god
so how do these secular scientists
account for our existence without a
creator
many cosmologists explain the
fine-tuning of our universe described in
this video
on the fine-tuning of inflationary
cosmology
lies in a new theory called the
multiverse
according to these scientists what we
used to call the universe
is not the whole enchilada not by a long
shot
in the multiverse theory our universe is
accompanied by not just one
two three other universes but perhaps by
an
infinite number of them some would be
too hot for life some would be too cold
for a life like ours to develop
but with an infinite number of them like
goldilocks some would be just right
to supporters of the multiverse paradigm
our existence is an accident that was
bound to happen
in such a capacious cosmos what's
surprising though
is that even scientists who believe in
the multiverse admit there's no hard
data supporting it
how is a scientist supposed to evaluate
an idea for which there is no evidence
in 1959 carl popper devised a way to
test if an idea was truly scientific
or if it was pseudo-scientific
mumbo-jumbo cloaked in technical
dressing
at that time he was very much concerned
with astrology phrenology
and the new interpretation of dreams
popularized by sigmund freud and others
he said if there's no way to disprove a
claim if it can't be
falsified it's not science originally
his bet noir was astrology
whose practitioners divine the fate of
individuals from the positions of
celestial bodies in the day
of their birth popper said that
astrologers predictions were so nebulous
that nothing could falsify them
here's a typical horoscope for me a
virgo
today will bring unexpected challenges
such a prediction is so imprecise it's
bound to be accurate
not only for my sign but for the 11
other ones as well
popper said it is typical of astrologers
tricks to predict things so
vaguely that the predictions can hardly
be failed
those among us who are unwilling to
expose their ideas to the hazard of
refutation
do not get to take part in the
scientific game
sadly for popper nowadays certain
newspapers devote more of their ink to
astrology than they do to astronomy
the reason is simple people are
naturally biased to believe vague but
accurate explanations of their fates
especially when it comes from authority
despite stereotypes of the contrary we
scientists are people too
we sometimes want to believe things that
comport with our own theories and
discard discordant data
a phenomenon known as confirmation bias
scientists also represent
society's most revered authorities
unfortunately the combination of
authority bias and confirmation bias is
leading to some pretty unscientific
effects
especially when it comes to the biggest
theory of them all quite literally
the multiverse take nobel laureate
steven weinberg to weinberg the
multiverse's
infinite vastness is a good piece of
news
it offers a reason why quote we find
ourselves in a universe favorable to
life
that does not rely on the benevolence of
a creator
and so if correct will leave still less
support for
religion it sounds to me like he's
arguing on behalf
of the atheist position but this could
be bad news when it comes to the
scientific method
for as physicist paul davies of arizona
state university has said
invoking an infinity of unseen universes
to explain the unusual features of the
one we do see
is just as ad hoc is invoking an unseen
creator
the multiverse theory may be dressed up
in scientific language
but in essence it requires the same leap
of faith
now davies is a noted cosmologist who
has made contributions including things
like the bunch davies vacuum and other
things that we'll explore on this
channel
and weinberg is noted for his famous
quip when posing the question of whether
or not he would bet his life
or his dog's life on the existence of
the multiverse quip that he would bet
martin reese's dog's life and andre
linde's life
on the existence of the multiverse and
it's notable to me
that people like linde will say things
to the fact that they would bet their
life
and we should not have more bias towards
the existence of a universe namely one
universe
over the existence of multiple universes
to quote lindae in his own words
since any data or even the absence of
data could be considered consistent with
the multiverse
this model of cosmogenesis could be
immune to falsification
because of this some of the detractors
of the multiverse call it a theory of
anything
reminding me of gk chesterton's quip
reportedly when men stop believing in
god
they don't believe in nothing they
believe in anything in the case of the
multiverse
chesterton's wisecrack is literally true
the same scientists who reject god's
existence due to insufficient evidence
have placed their faith in a theory
which seemingly neglects the scientific
method
to be fair there are other proposals out
there that can
test the multiverse hypothesis and some
say it's just a matter of time before
evidence is found
but be wary when a cosmologist tells you
to be patient
could take a billion years or so until
we know the answer until then
cosmologists must keep the faith
i'll put here some links to papers where
people do attempt to make predictions as
to what we'd see if the multiverse
did have universes like our own or maybe
even unlike our own
that we could come into causal contact
with and perhaps see the imprint of
perhaps through
so-called circles in the sky and the
cosmic microwave background scenarios
we'll explore those in future videos now
as cosmologists struggle to explain the
universe we do see
to explain the very existence of time
space energy
and even life scientists should take a
candid accounting of our motivations
why do we support the theories that we
do support if we do so with honesty
we can remain in popper's scientific
game
otherwise we might just be taking a huge
leap of faith
if you enjoyed this video you definitely
want to check out this playlist with
my cosmology friends talking about the
origin and evolution of the universe
and if you're interested in a deep dive
in the multiverse wormholes and other
exotic phenomena
click here and hear my conversation with
juan maldasena of the institute for
advanced study
enjoy and don't forget to subscribe for
more amazing content